too many people
listen you know how i'm looking at my
age you're young you guys are young and
which i love
i really do i'm at the age where i know
i'm gonna live 20 [ __ ] more years
i know that sounds morbid it's not
morbid at all i'll be [ __ ] 80 then i
think you'll go more than that
i'll take [ __ ] 80. healthy where i
can get a heart on i can [ __ ] do
everything i want
i take 80. i got 20 years left it's not
a lot you got [ __ ] 50 60 years though
him he's you know you guys have a lot in
technology and everything so
your brains are different your mind i'm
a little bit different
in the fact that i really understand my
mortality
because i've been i've been shot i've
been stabbed you've been shot i've been
shot and stabbed twice
where'd you get shot i got shot right
through the head you never missed once
right in in a robbery if if anyone goes
to my video you're [ __ ]
right no not it it went right across the
top blood was coming down here
oh and my brother was shot in the back
and into the arm
[ __ ] yeah we had a [ __ ] that was the
getaway if they go on my video on my
youtube
go to my play do you know my playlist is
the one of the most watched playlists
really the gangster redemption series on
my playlist
if you go to my my youtube channel go to
the playlist
it's called the gangster i'm the only
one who's ever took his book
and actually narrated the whole book in
chapter the chapter in the video
that's what really got that's pretty
amazing yeah that hook that's what
started this whole day
wow but that's in it when i got the
[ __ ] getaway it was a [ __ ] movie
getaway the bullets flying
[ __ ] this crazy [ __ ] but
so i look at my mortality different dan
if that makes sense yeah yeah yeah
and i think obviously we all should i
mean let me ask you a question
if you [ __ ] found out you had six
months to live
what would you do hmm
if i had six months to live i'd pay the
doctor an extra couple thousand dollars
get an extra six months
yeah it'd be i wish it was that easy
yeah no [ __ ] i don't know
it's a good question i love doing this
man this is fun i like no i know you do
but you know
think about your life what would you do
would you i don't know i i i hope
there's things i
would do i would go surf every single
wave
in the world all the best way you know
you're a big fan of spots and i don't
know
why i travel i've never been to hawaii
no yeah i was stationed there that's
amazing and i went body surfing i'll
never [ __ ] do almost
oh [ __ ] no man the [ __ ] kill rocks in
the reef oh my god
so i ended up 100 yards down today and i
was a great swimmer yeah
[ __ ] that's never in there but you i
never surfed you know i used to say they
can't put a cooler on that board i
couldn't do it
but the uh uh i ask people that
question is because think about
what you're doing now because you could
die in six months we all could obviously
or something can happen
but if you're not at least trying to
obtain something you know a lot of
people ask you you know what is success
right
and i was a multi-millionaire i was a
criminal i had my own limousine
multiple houses boats horses i was
[ __ ]
multi-millionaire really i was robbing
it i [ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] i was
dropping
millions of dollars a year so i [ __ ]
robbed 15 to 18 million once you've
giving a bunch of it to the mob though
no a percentage percentage and a bunch
of it not a bunch okay
no and i made a lot of money i mean i'd
live i lost two million dollars in
casinos gambling
i lost a quarter million dollars in two
weeks oh my cash
[ __ ] cash right you think i'm stupid
i am [ __ ] now
now i'm working but my point is uh
i i think people need to look it's not
just money
because money doesn't make it it really
doesn't things make it or
feelings or uh adventures or whatever it
is you know i had the houses the homes
the boats
and and my one sister says you know
you're always searching for something
and she was right because i i didn't
like a horse i bought two horses i
didn't want this houseboat another house
put another hospital on that boat a boat
bought a bigger boat
you know at what point is the thing i
like that you want to go surf somewhere
and go
do something or you know me now is more
i like interacting with people i like to
help people i want to go see the country
i know i'm doing that with the rv now
yeah
i'm going away for five weeks going up
to south dakota going to
mount rushmore maybe the badlands of
wyoming wow so i'm gonna do a few bunch
of things take videos and stuff like
that yeah enjoy that
but i i think everybody's gotta look at
that and say what's their
what are they gonna do in their own life
that
if they died like if i died right now if
i went home and you heard it you know
i already died right no if i no i want
to make sure you know
leave something i don't give listen will
you you came into this [ __ ] earth
naked
and [ __ ] nothing gives a [ __ ] if you
go out naked and [ __ ] nothing
the uh no i think you know
if i live if i went home and you heard
larry had a car accident holy [ __ ]
i hope you get on the [ __ ] thing and
say man i had a great interview with
larry
and you know what he lived a good life
because as much as i had the hard parts
in my life which i did
obviously in prison all that i also say
i lived a great life i didn't leave much
behind
you know it's not you know what i tell
people and and
you can equate it to sex to life to
anything don't ever lay on your death
bed
and say i should i will never lay and i
won't
and i mean i should have had sex with
this i should have tried yesterday
don't ever lay on your death and say i
shoulda i don't mean like
marilyn monroe you know what i meant
yeah trying something doing some i never
want to lay on my deathbed
and say you know i should or and i tell
people don't wait till you're too old
like you're 30 young good looking guy
have your life by the balls
now's the time because there'll be a
time when you can't
that's why i'm still lucky i'm healthy i
could do the my back hurts i have a very
bad back i back surgeries and stuff
really so i'll show you from the whole
bottom
i got a zip up my whole back really i
had a 12 15 vertebraes done in my oh
[ __ ] 15 what the [ __ ] happened yeah look
at [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] i i
was an injury or yeah i crushed my spine
in the service
oh and i had that here's for your camera
geez that's just the lower part i have
five vertebrae
my neck see if they can see that
damn yeah hold it back like where your
face is what's in focus yeah
damn it's pretty [ __ ]
brutal man and uh you know so and i've
done a lot so i'm a little pretty good
about
that you know i've done everything can
you still golf yeah a little hurt i
heard i can't
i used to hit a pretty good long ball
now i'm about 2 25 230 whatever
yeah yeah i'm going to do xanax after on
the ninth hole oh [ __ ] drugs the whole
[ __ ] oh yeah what do you want
well we'll bring we'll walk and bring
xanax wheat
coke a little like it is so much like it
in whatever you want yeah
eight boxes and eight balls
absolutely the uh i saw i'm a believer
that's why i'm a believer in
free sex free drugs free stuff meaning
and again
responsibly right i never say you know
everything in moderation
protect can't be stupid enough to kill
yourself you know as i say to people
in all dictions and i and anything
you control it don't let it control
right no matter what it is could be
[ __ ]
eaten sex drugs
i don't care call what they're all the
same money money
don't let it control you you control it
and do it
live your life i'm a big believer in
that
and and until and then live your life
i mean again then don't wait till your
70s i mean i'm [ __ ] oh i
should have did that i could have tried
that already i could have did this
yeah then you're [ __ ] too old you
know what i'm saying
i mean and i was always lucky where i'm
a pretty free thinker
and uh free spirit if you want to call
it that and i don't give a [ __ ] what
people think as you can tell
uh i'm saying it on the air so i don't
give a [ __ ] i really don't
uh cause unless you're paying me what
the [ __ ] am i
you judge me right you know i don't
believe in judging anybody i really
don't in anything
i am no better than any man on this
earth or no worse
i don't care who they are how much money
they make or how good-looking they are
how big their dick is or whatever the
[ __ ] it is
we're all the same we all put our pants
on the same way
i've met mega celebrities mega people
nothing impresses me unless the person
impresses me right because of
his smart you guys impressed you do yeah
yeah i was happy to see you guys i
watched a few of your videos i didn't
know how this would go
thanks man but you you know you're
working hard i love it keep doing it and
do you
do your thing and i love that i love
them people do that
because now you're making stuff now
you're going to look back and say wow we
had a great time we did this we tried
this whatever
i've done it my whole life and i always
was for my i always worked for myself
whether it was a mobster or not
but it just i didn't have that mentality
to be constricted you know creative
people can't be constricted right
if they are then they're never gonna
they're never gonna be truly happy
and you could be broke and happy as a
[ __ ] and i and i
i appreciate that i've been i hung out
with some dude man he
[ __ ] he had an old old rv
i mean 70 something a little [ __ ]
the happiest [ __ ] we were smoking ash
what a [ __ ] good time i had with that
guy
i mean and boy the stories where he went
and this
and and he was truly happy i sat back if
i was [ __ ] up
and we're sitting drinking drinking and
smoking and hey
[ __ ] that'll [ __ ] you up oh [ __ ] yeah
well and
and i i was so i thought about that for
a while since
it's the happiest guy in the world man
he didn't need
see that's another thing i don't need
the i had it
the houses the homes the big my own limo
and the driver
i don't need that anymore